hello and welcome to this video playing
to walk to bore I don't really know what
he does sometimes you immediately have
an idea what kind of opening some guys
play but yeah I simply don't remember so
we get a maraca see bind here I usually
go in three okay it's not a huge
difference why is it looking and it
should take we should takes 9650 196
that's just bloody right by the state
work
nachi for really works there when we're
the only two I think all Queen d2
sometimes you can do that
yeah it probably confuse to move all
also and play to the tattoo quickly
he goes going to be seven I go f3 right
yeah there's some trick move available
yeah I have 3m attacking the bishop what
do I sign something something more I
know elegant but it does work in
something else don't think so ok here i
can just I can take the bishop it I
wonder if Bishop d4 as an idea he's got
a size ok that means i have to take it
ok now he's still threatens on c3 Queen
a4 would be a queen trade yeah this is
actually good check the queen is a bit
actors there and annoying so trading it
off is probably fine yeah more or less
have to do that Quincy six maybe
now let's just wait what he does Quincy
6 no be 593 be 495 should be fine with
the thread on c7 blank red onyx ok now
it's very little and here they can do
I'm pretty well coordinated him yeah i
think it was mostly kind of a little
mouse clipper team must affirm confuse
some more water there is a way to play
on to play on my chief already in them
and then this variation this is the line
right here the queen is on g4 on it and
there is also in the game continuation
give castles and this is also a playable
line and i just wondered he did that the
the engine is not giving a wind
interestingly enough it should take
official takes defaults playable Wow
mina k and it doesn't look like the
greatest line ever but it's able to
piece it's pretty amazing you have to do
exactly this this sequence this ok and
then that position is not much fun for
black I mean I'm usually kind of
skeptical about those weaknesses hear
that um times I think they are not a big
problem but here that looks weak and
there I have the ideal minor piece here
with the knight on c3 so that was still
possible and in here he just recaptured
because he felt like everything's fine
at him here you just didn't just lose
the house can't we need for its really
very little icky I just probably return
and some nothing going on he can take
him ok but so this is some I think think
fairly easy for why because the current
ea7 is hanging and I kind of get the
tempe to activate and those pawns are
not that bad day they stopped all kinds
of porn breaks for black yeah ok guys
thanks for watching and now I should
switch it on earlier that is this ever
ok I told you all the things thanks for
watching again